thank you
okay do I need to start again
how much do I need to get everything
just a little bit
okay members will recall that we as a
counselor required to produce an annual
statement of uh the infrastructure
um that annual statement which must be
in place by December for the preceding
monitoring year must include as a
minimum an infrastructure list a section
106 report a sill report Stan setting
out standard information on income and
spend for the previous Financial year
and details of the council's still
spending protocol this is the fourth
version
um members the infrastructure funding
statement is at appendix 4 on page 13.
have an officer here if anybody has any
questions the recommendation is that the
infrastructure statement
be recommended for adoption by council
do I have any
counselor Junior do you have a question
I know that at the office at the
overview
at the over and scrutiny committee there
was quite considerable
um debate on this
is going to be committed there was
considerable debate and the chairman of
ovian scrutiny will probably be
elaborate on that one but the question
that was raised at Albion scrutiny was
about the size of the monies that are
unallocated for more than a year in some
cases within the district councils
um bank account and just the question
that was raised was
um how do we oversee and review the
projects for which these monies are
meant for in order that they don't stay
in the bank account
um at longer than necessary so what is
the process that by which they are
reviewed
thank you councilor junid I will ask uh
Joe to come in and make a comment before
I make any further comment Joe would you
like to make a comment at all
right yes thank you Council Pemberton
um yes I think um I mean it depends the
section 106 amenities obviously you've
got a different process for monitoring
and
um people on top of and spending those
monies as opposed to the sell monies the
film monies is a process set out with
the infrastructure within the
infrastructure funding statement about
how those monies are allocated and spent
and then a report is presented to
Cabinet each year as to an update on
those allocations
um in terms of section 106 menus I think
it depends on the type of money it is
for example the affordable housing
Mondays which I know does perform quite
a big chunk of the
um section 106 minutes that the Council
of currently in receipt of there's
obviously a separate process and housing
investment panel or the hip which looks
at allocating those monies so
it varies and obviously each section 106
money has got a section 106 agreement
which sets out
um you know the parameters within which
that money has to be spent and any
deadlines for spend of those monies and
obviously each department that's
responsible for spending those monies
obviously monitors it keeps an eye on
um the time scales for spend
thank you um
thank you that that that's it before I
make a comment with section 106 and a
follow-up question was particularly from
uh two of the Ulster members was about a
particular project which is environment
agency in Ulster and the the project
Partnerships uh and how those are
managed by the council
okay so I think
um Joe has explained I think for just
for some clarity
um section 106 monies are Guided by the
legal agreement and the time scales
within those
um
I am aware that uh there has been uh
some uh question around ensuring that
um
we avoid getting into a situation where
we might be at risk of returning Monies
to a developer
and the head of service has now agreed a
protocol whereby uh under section 106
any suggestion of any money is being
returned to a developer will require
sign off of the head of service and the
development portfolio holder before any
such uh agreement is made clearly we
want to avoid if at all possible
um
returning Monies as far as still is
concerned I think members need to
remember that
um we are the holder of Monies and
projects are submitted
and frankly it's for the uh the project
owners to drive those projects forward
there is not currently a review
mechanism
nor would I support in The Current
financial circumstances allocating
additional office of resource to an
additional review mechanism
officers have sufficient awareness of
the Dynamics of relationships between
various stakeholders for example
environment agency
and I can assure members of cabinet
Ulster members
um overview in scrutiny and your
self-counselor junior did your role as
opposite opposition leader that
officers are
active in having conversations where it
is appropriate to ensure that there are
no
undue delays I have been party to at
least one conversation about a project
where there was some negotiation
required to include environment agency
and particularly when we're dealing with
environment agency my observation is
that they move to a different time scale
to
us and frankly
you can push as hard as you like but
they appear to be in a position where
they come to things in their own sweet
time
so I would like to give assurance that
officers do
through business as usual keep an eye
but I'd have to say I am not in favor
and I noted the chair of osc's comments
I'm not in favor of
allocating additional resource for an
additional monitoring report at this
point I think we cover we cover
exceptions out sufficiently so if we
look at them there's a significant silk
project that clearly is not going to go
ahead
um we understand that those monies will
go back into the pot and new bids will
come along so I think hopefully with
that
um perhaps I'm also going to look to the
chair of osc whether that covers your
email as well chair of osc councilor
Crump
councilor microphone I think I was
deliberate actually to give me quite and
I'll tell blame it yeah I think once
like to touch on a bit later if that's
okay but it's I think that's really
acceptable thank you
councilor Cargill politics I missed you
there thank you very much uh picking
that point up if I may also OC we
discussed
um some of the projects that have
stalled a little bit and how to push
them over the line now I should explain
that we had this yes it is
we did discuss
resourcing this morning so we fully
appreciate your concerns about over
stretching uh the the the opposite time
appreciate that however some projects
and I did explain the one at RC which is
this one in Ulster uh it's a quite a
complicated one it needs that little bit
of extra push to get it over the line
and that's perhaps something that we can
do as a council it's it's more officer
LED yes but member LED two it's just
having that little bit of extra push to
get things over the line and then yes
the whole projects can go and we can get
what we want sorted so that's a
recommendation coming I believe so just
touch back on that as as I said a minute
or two ago
um I've sat in on a conversation
um with members and officers about
trying to move as it happens a flood
scheme along not in Ulster so officers
are alive to that and the two shipster
members are nodding that they were
involved in this particular conversation
so officers are alive to that and are
driving conversations where they see
projects are stored and if that
particular project is one where there's
a feeling that there is stalling then
I'm sure the officers have heard your
concerns loud and clear and I think
that's a sort of business as usual thing
rather than as I say adding an overlay
of further formal monitoring
so with uh members of cabinet
with that
we all agreed
thank you
I thought I'd left that switched on I am
really playing a Blinder today aren't I
next item UK shared Prosperity fund and
rural England shared Prosperity fund the
lead member councilor Jefferson is not
here I do have to my left Tony perks who
has worked uh on the uh on the
submission the recommendations here are
that the submission
um to rural England's shared Prosperity
investment plan
um
be submitted as an addendum to the
previously submitted UK shared
Prosperity fund investment plan
and that Authority is given to the
deputy chief executive to my left in
consultation with the leader absence the
monitoring officer and section 151
officer to my right and to my left to
finalize and submit
the rural England Prosperity fund
addendum investment plan and take any
further actions to seek and secure
delivery of UK SF and repf and subject
to the recommendations one and two
approve the terms of reference for the
local Prosperity Advisory Group and the
decision-making process set out in
paragraph 1.4 of the report members I'm
sure that you will have read the report
I will defer to
Mr Perks to answer any questions do I
have any questions around I have
councilor Junaid uh it's um the question
again was rated over you in scrutiny is
uh I I attended The Advisory Group and
that was extremely useful uh and it
would be very useful for us all to be
updated as soon as we know that that
government is actually going ahead with
this funding and the finalization
because there was certainly a lot of
uncertainty at that meeting that would
need to be addressed thank you yeah the
meeting was the day after the Autumn
statement I wasn't able to attend so uh
I think yes we're all seeking Clarity Mr
Perks
we will look to update the group of
students we've got more information it's
a bit of a moving piece with the
government we're proceeding in sort of a
combination of Hope and expectation at
the moment
um just trying to meet the deadlines we
do need to get this some supplementary
sort of funding plan in by the end of
the week so if um I can have the cabinet
support for that we'll make sure that we
at least meet that deadline and as and
when we get allocated some money we'll
reconvene the group and hope this import
some good work
foreign
the recommendation is set out on page 71
pardon me recommendations one two and
three are they agreed members
thank you very much members we now move
to the next item
on page 81 of your papers
um which is uh duty to cooperate and
statements of common ground
and that is one where
I'm the lead member for that one but we
also have Joe with us
um
we are required under the current regime
um
to evidence that we have met the
government's requirements under duty to
cooperate
um that's not the same as the duty to
actually provide a solution I think
members should remember that it is a
duty to cooperate it is not which is not
the same as necessarily being the
solution
um so as part and parcel of that during
plan making activities
there is a process to
narrow down areas of issue between
neighboring authorities hence the
creation of the statements of Common
Ground so for example evidence bases
will be agreed Etc so the recommendation
here is that Authority is delegated to
the leader in conjunction with the
portfolio holder for place and the head
of development to sign statements of
common ground in respect of plan making
activities and in so doing ensure that
um
we take into account comments made by
our partners in the development of the
South Warwickshire local plan Warwick
District Council I have Joe here any
questions thoughts observations
councilor shenton
Mr uh people I understand it this this
statement of
um
acutely to cooperate cooperate
and of common ground is that are there
counter signatories if you like from all
the other lpas to this or is it just we
say we're going to cooperate
so so there are two things there there's
the overarching duty to cooperate and
one of the
um mechanics of that if you will is the
preparation of a statement to Common
Ground and that could be between two
authorities or it could be between a
number of authorities most of the time
you'll find there's more than two
authorities in a given housing market
area so a number of signatories is that
correct yeah
uh yes absolutely sure yeah I mean it
depends on the Strategic Master at hand
um it could be like you said between
just between two authorities if it's on
a particular matter or it could be
between 14 15 different authorities
um on a different matter so it very much
varies on what that strategic issue is
that's that's subject to that statement
thank you Joe
um any other questions or observations
if not then the recommendation is as set
out on page 21 are we all agreed
thank you very much members of cabinet
um the next item under resources
portfolio 180 page 85 of your papers
treasury management mid-year review
2022-2023 lead member is councilor
Harvey councilor Harvey
foreign
this paper is presented because it forms
part of the monitoring process for which
members are responsible it fulfills a
requirement under the set for code of
practice
yes
it fulfills a requirement under the sit
for code of practice on Treasury
management
the seven areas addressed by this report
are set out in paragraph 1.2.2 on page
86 of the papers
when the corresponding report was
presented to the cabinet on 6th of
December last year I concluded my
introductory remarks by identifying
three broad messages that were relevant
at that time
the context for my remarks at that time
was the MPC had set Bank rated 0.1
percent
that forecasters were suggesting that
interest rates could rise to one percent
in 2022 and a further rise to 1.5
percent in 2023
against this back cloth I pointed out
that one interest rates had been at
historically low rates and could be
expected to rise in 2022 although they
will remain at historically modest
levels
secondly movements movements in
financial markets were the result of
perceptions of the economy of the impact
of economic changes for example the
worldwide effect on Supply chains
arising from the impact of covid-19
pandemic leading to volatility in asset
prices and yields and to shortages in
energy supplies leading to cost of
living pressures and the resultant
levels of higher inflation and consumer
confidence thirdly in the context of
continued uncertain financial markets
the council's cautious Approach at that
time to where and how its runs were held
was well merited
there have been two major events
subsequently that have exacerbated the
trends to which are referred
the first was Russia's decision to
invade Ukraine and the consequential
disruptive economic and inflationary
impact this has had on world markets in
general
the second was the trust
administration's mini budget of 23rd
September
this demonstrated in unambiguous terms
when an attempt is made to implement
economic policy on the grounds of a
dogmatic politic ideology regardless of
the reality of the state of the
country's economy and its finances there
will be predictable consequences for
interest rates inflation rates and
institutional and international
credibility
taken together these two major events
have had this have had significant
consequence for the UK's economy with
which the sunac Administration has had
to confront
section two of the review Paints the
picture in some detail and includes the
prediction by the link Asset Management
Group the bank rate will rise to five
percent in the early months of 2023 and
remained at that level for most of the
remainder of the year
paragraph 5.5 councilor Barker records
the gross yield in the half year to the
end of September of 1.16 slightly short
of The Benchmark rate whilst paragraph
5.6 points out that interest income
generated year to date is 147 000 pounds
above budget a clear demonstration of
the impact of the government's economic
policy on interest rates and hence on
the council's income
a meeting of the cash manager working
group was held last week on Tuesday the
22nd November when the prospects for the
remainder of this year and for next were
reviewed as well as the relative
performance of our current fund manager
paragraph 6.1 points out that the
council currently has no external
borrowings and paragraph 6.2 state that
it's not it is not anticipated that the
council will borrow any funds during the
remainder of the financial year other
than as already authorized in relation
to the material recycling facility due
to open next year
the broad messages I draw from this
report therefore are one interest rates
have increased are likely to increase
further and are likely to remain high by
the standard of the past 10 years for
the foreseeable future
until the domestic rate of inflation
subsides significantly
secondly movements in financial markets
are the inevitable consequence of Market
perceptions of the impact of changes in
economic policies as the past three
months have amply demonstrated
and thirdly the council's cautious
approach to where and how its funds are
held is well merited I ask therefore
Deputy leader that this report reviewing
the treasury management of the council's
funds over the first half of the current
Financial year is received thank you
thank you councilor Harvey does Mr
Burrell as a section 151 officer have
any comments or anything to add to that
at all I have nothing to add sir
thank you
um any questions observations
with that then uh I think the report is
received
thank you next item is item number eight
on page 97 of your agenda uh the Grange
Hall South where councilor Harvey is the
lead member and the lead officer is Tony
perks
councilor Harvey
thank you
this is a shorter introduction
this paper seeks Authority for specified
officers and the relevant portfolio
holder to negotiate and degree suitable
terms to transfer the council's half
share in the ownership of this Community
Hall in southam to southam Town Council
which owns the other half of the share
in return for a nominal sum
this transfer is based on the
recognition that Salem Town Council
already undertakes the day-to-day
management of this locally valued
Community facility
the transfer would have the effect of
eliminating these council's current
responsibility for 50 of the building's
maintenance costs
this is not regarded as a contentious
matter rather it's a pragmatic proposal
that provides local Clarity within
southam over ownership maintenance and
operation of this valued Community Hall
I ask therefore Deputy leader that the
two recommendations as set out on page
97 of the papers of this meeting are
agreed thank you thank you councilor
Harvey I can see that councilor Crump
has indicated a wish to speak before
doing so I'm just going to bring Mr
Perks in have you any comments or
observations at all Mr Perks
um no The Proposal came to us from the
um tanks that say them who were
interested in taking over
um the sort of full control of the hall
as you point as Council Harvey pointer
they've been operating it
um for many years they run the stewards
they run the day-to-day interests and
the report sets out sort of details
about how we could affect our transfer
should members be dishonestly doing so
thank you Mr Perks councilor Crump
come on James Mr chairman yeah I think
it makes sense
um because at the moment the Hall's
serving two masters or Mr Sears or
whichever phrase is appropriate these
days
um so again I think makes sense there
will be cost savings to the district
council obviously which we'll have to
discuss sometime councilor Harvey
um but I think it makes sense and
um
yeah the the tiny support I've not had
any uh residents say this is not a good
idea
and as like a wood member myself and
councilor Bromwich are supportive of the
situation because again it avoids
ambiguity and that's the last thing we
want in the local government thank you
thank you members of cabinets any
questions observations
cancer Kettle it was a neighboring Ward
member this is an excellent facility
um and I'm sure Southern tongue council
with the condition that if there is any
future again we'll come back that will
come back to us I think it's an
excellent way to go forward
thank you councilor Kettle and with that
then uh the recommendations are set out
on page 97 of your papers have we all
agreed
thank you very much members
um next item is item nine on page 107 of
your papers
uh the heart shared service partnership
lead member councilor Barker and I see
we have Nick cadd has arrived as as the
lead officer councilor Barker
um the hori issue of the heart shared
service partnership
raises its head again and I can say that
quite confidently this time progress has
been made
um the recommendations you will find on
page 107 include a short
um
claim that we have made progress
um I'm talking about the implication of
the white paper for social care and not
necessarily knowing what is in the
future for any of us with that plus uh
talking about the five-year new
five-year partnership agreement
but giving delegated authority to me
plus officers to
um negotiate it and or
withdraw if there are any questions of
detail I suggest that you ask Mr cadd
about them
thank you members are coming at any
questions
councilor Junaid
the main question that was asked over
ovian scrutiny was it's just an
observation that
it is the arm's length nature of the
Partnerships that possibly is is a
weakness and we did ask whether to make
sure that that the operational
Management Services it is one of the
risk assessments number 6.3 we just
asked assurance that that risk
assessment had been properly considered
Mr CAD would you like to uh make any
response or observation on that at all
we have I'm just flipping down to uh six
point whatever it was to uh do a double
double check that when I say we have uh
we actually have
um sorry Witcher six points six point
three six point three okay
which will be picked up through will be
picked up through the board yeah
definitely yeah because we do keep
coming backwards and forwards with LSC
and I get where you're coming from on
this because
you're not the only one
so yeah
are we okay with these recommendations
so I'll
thank you counselor Barker so any other
questions observations therefore is
cabinets
happy with the recommendations outlined
one to six on page 107 are we all agreed
agreed thank you very much
the next item on your papers on page 127
is a review
a review of the housing strategy action
plan page one two seven once again the
lead member is councilor Barker and I
can see that we have Renata from the
housing team
um
we're not just here to answer the
difficult questions
um this review of the housing extraction
a lot of the strategy action plan
um I think is uh stunning I'm also very
pleased that there are colorful pictures
which make it a lot more easy to
understand when you turn to page to the
to appendix one
which actually shows the action plan and
the times and the aims
um
all I'm asking is that the report's
noted and that the revised action plan
is agreed if anybody's got any questions
on it then
I'll have a go and I'm sure Renato will
have things to say
so but all in all I think it's great any
any questions any observations
okay with that the recommendation on
page 157
uh sorry one two seven
um that the revised action plan be
agreed and the report is noted are we
all in agreement with that
noted and agree thank you next item on
page 157
is delivering local needs and local
Choice Rural Housing and again the lead
member councilor Barker and I can see
that Renata is joined by Sarah Brooke
Taylor from um Warwickshire rural
housing as their rural housing enabler
welcome to Cabinet uh councilor Barker
oh quick rush through rural housing now
um
again quite simple
um that one of the aims of the
sustainable homes strategy is to support
communities to build sustainable
affordable homes using rural enabling
and uh hence that's the reason that
Sarah is here to answer questions if
there are any but the recommendation per
appendix one is that the approach to
delivering homes for local people in
rural areas be noted
thank you catch the bucket
yeah I was just coming to you councilor
Junaid
again uh there was some discussion of
this and the previous item at um
the over in scrutiny uh just
I request that uh the housing strategy
is is something that comes on to their
agenda but just a request
um I know that there's been some
interest but also a lot of problems with
the Community Land trusts I'd like to be
able to on 1.4 point
two maybe at a later period not here and
now counselors could know how the
Community Land trusts
work and how how successful Community
Land Trust has achieved its goals and
the other question that I would ask is
more of award more of a an Ulster issue
but
um
okay okay
um Renata and or
um
Jill uh
Sarah where did I get Jail from just how
did we learn the lessons
so Renata and Sarah
um is I think the question is around the
efficacy of Community Land trusts member
engagement member understanding
um
what can be done uh to help members
support Community Land trusts and what
what's the uh what's the sort of track
record for Community Land Trust so far
people obviously in the local area we
just have the clavidan Community Land
Trust which has been attempting for a
number of years to bring forward some
properties I think the truth of the
matter is that locally we have tried and
tested method through the current
policies under what are referred to as
local needs or local Choice housing and
that's obviously where the bulk of my
work is if communities are interested in
Community Land trusts I do provide them
with information but it's a huge onus on
the community not only from a time and
effort point of view of volunteers but
funding as well so although people do
inquire about Community Land trusts they
then tend to turn I said to a tried and
tested method there are Community Land
trusts that have been successful in
other areas of the country and I'll be
happy to provide information about those
two councilor Julie thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
indeed can I just add something there I
think about you know the cleverdome one
having spent a lot of time talking to
the late John Horner about it it did
seem one of the most complicated things
you could possibly do and um if I'd been
John I'd have come to you and gone I've
had enough of this can you sort it out
please Sarah
noted that so yeah my other question
you've got something and then I got
Castle about something around Ulster
particularly let's take that and then
I've got councilor parry and councilor
shenton
it's just that there are two references
um two um commuted some sums from an
area one of them is just across the road
from my house which is Kenneth Farm Road
in fact both of them are uh and um both
of the the commuted Summers went
elsewhere uh to provide uh local needs
homes uh not not a problem that local
needs homes are provided but we are
struggling for some provision in Ulster
and I just want to make that point that
Ulster is wanting
um some local needs or social housing uh
to find a solution and I know it I've
raised it before but then I just want to
raise it again that there is a need
please keep raising it counselor unit
please do keep raising it
and I think my understanding is that it
wasn't for the lack of trying to
identify
where housing could be uh delivered
within Ulster
um I would just observe that the next
uh major opportunity I suspect will come
through the South Warwickshire local
plan in terms of identifying and I would
urge
Ulster members to be active in the
process to identify
um
small scale sites that start to meet
ulster's needs
make the point really because whilst I
was not a counselor there was there was
um some garage sites that we orbit
garage sites that could have been within
this time scale that was mentioned there
and yet they weren't um so it was an
opportunity lost I think
um that was a process we were not
entirely in control of as I understand
it
um so um your your point is made and the
the notion of a Housing Association
selling assets that then don't provide
um social rent housing just seems and
well it's an anathema to me and I I
struggle to understand how that sits
with any Housing Association but that's
merely a personal View and of course
other views are available counselor
Parry
thank you Deputy chair
um I just wondered whether we can use
aspects of this report or some evidence
towards the policy making process for
the South Warwickshire local plan in
particular to the ever
ever ongoing need that comes across
particularly from local Villages for
bungalows
and I really do feel that we do need to
be addressing the shortfall
amongst new developments of Bungalows
because it it occurs the whole time in
rural housing assessments and housing
need and I think the only way that we
can respond to this very important
mix of housing is to ensure that we
perhaps have something come through in
the new sarath Warwickshire local plan
that addressed this very important issue
uh your point is well made and I would
observe that in in my own ward in
Bedford with the support of the or
rather uh the the sort of negotiation by
the parish council in Bedford uh there
were some Bungalows delivered on one
particular site
um so your point is well made there I
had councilor shenton then I have
councilor Kettle have indicated
thank you chair um just a couple of
observations one is the Community Land
Trust the cleverton Community Land Trust
I actually joined
um that scheme when John was alive and
um uh stayed with it for about six
months and then left it because it it's
exactly as you say councilor Barker it
was incredibly
um incredibly difficult to get things
moving and your governed by company law
because you have to set it up properly
as well so it is incredibly difficult to
keep going
um they weren't helped by the fact that
the site they chose was smack on the
border with Norton Lindsay and uh so
that didn't help them on another score
being even more parochial
um is that the Bailey scheme which I'm
very grateful
um for Sarah for driving this scheme
along it is an excellent scheme it it
has its formal opening on the 12th of
December this is the advert at 5 30
Gwen's close and I would uh seriously I
don't know whether Sarah can take
anymore guess for the seriously ask
um members of the cabinet to come along
and see this scheme it really is an
excellent scheme the um the properties
are very nice inside they're carbon
negative
and there is nothing bad that I could
ever say about this scheme it is
brilliant
um so I'm very grateful to Sarah for
that um and that followed on the back
obviously of key Gardens in what we're
in as well and I would always recommend
the rural enabler Sarah and the team
there to help us in these matters rather
than the clts which are bogged down by
protocol
Gardens and the brilli scheme are
excellent schemes they're exemplars of
what can be achieved by a local
Authority working in Partnership and to
save Sarah the trouble the the checks in
the post are you uh yeah
and and uh actually I haven't visited
the brilli site at uh the early stages
I'd be Keen to get an opportunity to to
to be at the opening if at all possible
um and don't eat all the sandwiches
cancer sheltered uh I have councilor
Kettle then I have cancer genitive
indicated and then I'll probably think
about wrapping this wrapping the item up
cancer yeah I just following Council
Parish comments earlier on about
bungalows
um and of course we do have very
significant number of Bungalows which
are held by housing associations
um and uh that has historically been a a
noticeable
um trend of Housing Association it's not
to do with this policy we're discussing
today but this Council does need to push
back really hard on housing associations
are trying to set off uh Bungalows
because
um they are
a really important resource
for our residents whether private owned
or Housing Association owned
Point well made councilor Kathleen I'm
sure the officers have heard you loud
and clear Renata did you want to make a
comment at all
I would only say that obviously it's
within the the remit of the Housing
Association if they wish to to sell off
these properties a lot of them are very
much older properties so actually people
aren't wanting these properties uh
regardless whether or not the Housing
Association would be able to provide a
new tenancy as it under these properties
that actually a lot of them are just no
longer fit for purpose
um I think I'll just make the
observation that we've probably got to
be smart about this kind of thing
um
I I I I have I have some in my own Ward
where I think that the Housing
Association would be inclined to to get
rid of them
um and I think losing them to the social
stock
um
from my perspective I think
um whilst the investment might not
necessarily wash its face in the short
term I think that and I'm then looking
to the chair for of the housing
investment panel that perhaps there
might be a route through that as a
backstop to keep some of those single
single story properties Within
um within the social rented sector if at
all possible and perhaps that might be
something that
um the the investment panel could could
take a look at at some point
well whilst I would be minded to as the
chairman of the housing investment panel
all I would say is with there has to
that really does need to be a
demonstrable need and there might be a
smarter way of doing it as well so we
will certainly consider I will leave
councilor Barker to find different ways
to skin that particular cat
cancel the tune it and then I'll wrap
the item up I'm just wondering whether
there's a role for the rural enabler to
work with Parish councilors that
declined to do housing needs survey
perhaps it perhaps
perhaps no perhaps to encourage them
maybe to work with adjoining uh town or
Parish councils maybe to that might be a
way in which it perhaps if they feel
they cannot afford maybe that's the way
that they could do it
um to to find out whether there is um
you know there is a housing need in a
particular area before I bring Sarah in
I might observe that counselor Junior
you could be you could have you could be
forgiven but I think you're probably
touching a raw nerve there with Sarah
I think the phrase leading the horse to
water might be the right of the phrase
perhaps I can I can assure councilor
junid that where we have difficulties
engaging with the parish council I do
then come directly to the counselors and
ask for their assistance I think
councilor Cargill might remember a
couple of years ago I asked for his
assistance in approaching a particular
Parish Council and even he was having
trouble uh approaching that particular
Council so we do do our very very best
to work with all appropriate parishes
but I think it has to be understood that
uh you know I I do have time constraints
I only work full-time and so I do tend
to
I do tend to work with Parish councils
that are happy to work with me
thank you again I would observe I I have
personal experience of you know an
understanding of Sarah uh having tried
to work hard with a number of Parish
councils who frankly just aren't
interested and again I can't understand
that
um so uh yeah I would just uh place on
record my thanks for her work and what
do you mean you only work part-time well
that's what the weekends are for
the only workforter yes what are the
weekends for and Christmas Day
I made sure a lot of evenings at Parish
Council
right with that the recommendation is on
page 157
and the recommendation is that the
approach is noted I think there are some
good pieces that have come out of this
discussion that I'm sure officers and
Sarah can take away thank you very much
next item item 12 on your agenda on page
179
all right are we all agreed on that
thank you and there we moved to page
179 item 12 which is the mid-year
performance report counselor Perry the
lead member and I can see Simon purfield
is here
um councilor Parry thank you Deputy
leader basically in a nutshell this is a
summary of performance from April to
September on the delivery of the council
plan and key performance indicators
across the operations
the actions cover the period from April
2022 to September 2023 which allow for
excuse me the actions
over the period
the actions not the report the actions
perhaps if I have actions point two two
points yeah yes keep going
the actions cover the period from April
2022 to September 2023 allow for the new
Administration to develop a new council
plan from October 2023 to September
2027.
65 actions have been agreed for the
period April 2022 to September 2023 and
25 are due for reporting this quarter
eight tasks have been achieved 16 are on
target or ongoing and one task was not
achieved by the Target deadline which is
the task and finish group review in
relation to the lessons learned from the
merger but this review has commenced and
is scheduled for completion next month
there are 21 key performance indicators
which monitor performance in year three
16 relate to the council plan objective
and five are corporate health indicators
details of the seven kpis which are not
on target are highlighted in the report
key factors to a number of KPS is being
off Target reflect impact on resources
due to unfilled vacancies and staff
sickness however recruitment of new
additional staff for the right caliber
has progressed well
star flow staff workloads continue to be
high at present and their dedication to
their roles is greatly appreciated
does anyone have any specific questions
which the respective Cabinet member will
be able to respond to otherwise the
recommendations are to no performance
achieved during April to September 2022
in year three of the council plan and to
note performance against key performance
indicator targets
thank you councilor Perry any specific
questions counselor Harvey on our note
we have Mr per field here and I can see
that councilor crumpus chair of osc has
indicated as well councilor Harvey
not a question can I apologize to
councilor Ferry for that uh unwarranted
Interruption I'm glad she did wasn't
knocked off as stride
your apology is duly noted councilor
Harvey councilor crumpf
hopefully I won't have to apologize
um yeah we talked about performance
um at the RSC and one of the areas
unsurprisingly was talked about was the
sickness levels
um sickness levels we've discussed
Allied to retention and recruitment
um the impact on Service delivery and I
think won the performance targets was
CCTV not being met
um so again it would be
hopefully by the third quarter we would
hope to see some some improvement so
um we'll probably wait till the third
quarter and once that third quarter has
come about and if there isn't any
Improvement we would want to know why
um also we noticed in the report there
was a couple of targets despite it being
Quarter Two some targets were still to
be confirmed
I've noticed at least one I found might
be a couple so again this might have
been a misprint or whatever and
um we also commented about the
performance on the one two three plus
which I'll probably talk about them a
little bit later so again that's
encouraging so
um I think it the overall flavor from
osc was
um it was encouraging but there are some
things that we would probably need for
the clarification at the end of quarter
three
thank you councilor Crump so uh unless
there are any other questions
observations counselor Perry I'd just
like to respond back to councilor Crump
if I may
um the other aspect obviously we've now
introduced a hybrid form of working for
staff members and obviously
having a work to home and a hybrid a
mixed
form of working over this whole of the
2022 until it's recently changed
inevitably has had some form of the
impact as well but what I can say is the
new hybrid form seems to be working well
staff members are pleased to be back
into the office I think they're
certainly warmer over the next few
months and
safe to say some excellent appointments
have been made through a very thorough
and comprehensive recruitment process
and as you well know councilor Crump SDC
is very much a council that will recruit
the right person into the right role
rather than just recruit
thank you very much Council Parry
councilor Cargill just for reference to
cabinet at jcng this morning there's a
reporter as a status survey and it did
cover some of this
um so it might be worth circulating that
I believe that's coming in a bit of
future agenda thank you very much
councilor Cargill so with that cabinet
recommendation is to note the
performance achieved and note the
performance against the kpi targets
agreed thank you very much
we now moved to part C issues arising
from overview and scrutiny committee I
invite councilor Crump to make any
observations I I know he has shared an
email but if he wishes to make some
further observations
um publicly yeah just really briefly
um
we talked about the one two three plus
uh at the RSC with their presentation
from officers and Council Fleming and
obviously there's positive news about
the 10 increase in recycling and the 33
reduction in residual waste and
reduction of fly tipping it's amazing
what you get when you change your
portfolio holders and it gets the [ __ ]
um
no but that that was positive
um not the case agenda's removal the
positive uh presentation
um obviously we're expressing our
gratitude to the officers for the hard
work Lounge in the new contract and
again there's more emphasis on assisted
collections again we should we need to
protect our vulnerable women's Society
so that was really positive
um we've touched about the
infrastructure funding statement in
cancer Junior and catch the cargo of
both eloquently
um summarized most of what we talked
about but the another hat off of
information is that the environment
agency has been strongly encouraged by
government departments to complete
schemes within the original time scales
and bring others forward
so that hopefully will remove some of
the
blockages
and any of the ponds that are osc that
counts the cargo was making of course I
didn't respond
um so again that was really positive
heart again we noted the amount of Works
being being cut was limited by financial
resources which is a lot of which is
outside our control
noted the improved performance in the
government's of heart and obviously
welcome the bright clause and a
potential contract from April 23 and the
implications from the white paper social
care
and we've just talked about performance
so there's nothing further to add on
that thank you
thank you for your observations there uh
thank you for your observations uh
councilor Chrome I am aware that there
has been a considerable amount of effort
undertaken particularly by officers to
provide overview in scrutiny with
um detailed updates in the very early
days of the 123 system
um I would
um perhaps make a plea that we are now
in a position where we need to start to
see how the service beds in the medium
and longer term
and so I think cabinets for you and I
think the portfolio holder's view is
that
um
we we should and will move away from
what has been almost monthly updates on
this and I think you need to be thinking
in terms of looking at an annual review
of how the system works I mean clearly
that is within your gift uh to request
the the updates that you you feel are
appropriate to deliver appropriate
overview in scrutiny but I think the
observation is that there has uh been an
awful lot of work and
um you start to become we start to get
to the law of diminishing returns until
we have a you know a much longer time
Horizon
um and I think yes I'm seeing the the
current and the former portfolio holder
um sort of nodding there and say oh no
you were blowing your nose there
cancerous Jensen
um
at the same time yes they are indeed a
double Act
the portfolio holders of Christmas Past
and Christmas present
counselor Crump it's going back briefly
on that yeah it's always a pleasure to
see Council Fleming and I'll cancel this
Jensen is our osc
um so yeah they've always all been very
welcome
um
just got the points I should have raised
back to council party
um certainly we've been well supported
with the recruitment process in the new
overview and scrutiny officer Mr Allison
who's proven to be a real asset and
really helpful and in keeping me on my
toes as well so it's great and the other
point the task and finish group on the
Lessons Learned we are making
significant progress I'm sharing that uh
We've slightly widened uh the people
were speaking to it's really for genuine
reasons and that we've interviewed sorry
the company shared intelligence of being
part funded by the LGA are coming up
some really good stuff both for us and
the lessons learned to buy the algaisr
so thank you uh I I probably should make
an apology here is this is more cock-up
than conspiracy but I've had to cancel
my interview twice for uh for day job
intervening so but I am due to be
speaking to them fairly shortly so
apologies for uh delay playing your good
work there
right I think that covers overview and
scrutiny Part D cabinet committees there
are non-party on block items I've not
had any requests made to me before the
meeting to discuss either items 13 or 14
um Part F other matters urgent business
are there any items of Virgin business
Mr park because there are none
thank you very much well with that
cabinet thank you for your uh for your
work today and as this is the final
cabinet meeting
scheduled for this year is that correct
I think the papers say the next one
scheduled is 9th of January
so with that may I wish you the wish you
all seasons greetings and a merry
Christmas and I'll be first first one in
that